let's go next to Dante from Florida so
Dante every time you call in I have more
detailed notes at one point you were
Ferg Bernie then you called in and you
were hardcore tulsi and if I recall
correctly last time you called in you
were still four tulsi but you were
voting Bernie instead or what's going on
now
well I always been a Bernie Sanders
supporter my number one candidate in the
race yeah we got in the race officially
right um
I support I defend toasting average
sometimes because I think she is running
a great campaign and she doesn't get the
credit she deserves from a lot of people
in progressive independent media so
there are certain issues that well under
she's talking about I'm for it and so
yeah so I'm one candidate but I will
defend Tulsi Gabbard got it okay so
Dante I want it I want to hear your
question but your connection is going in
and out so let's see if we can resolve
it and I do want to hear your question
all right is that better
yes it is all right so my question was
um
so Elizabeth Warren now that she's
running in the Democratic primary she
seems to have a lot of these plans and
ideas but it to me it comes off says
this she's grandstanding because she
didn't really have these plans or ideas
just a few years ago when she was in the
Senate so I don't I don't think you I
don't think a lot of people take that
into account Wendy what's an example of
a dragon Dante what's an example of
something that she's advocating for now
but wasn't a couple of years ago well
like her stance politics sorry sorry you
you're breaking up Dante her stance on
what her position on money in politics
she's not as against it as she claims to
be
she raised ten million dollars in big
money in the Senate campaign and she
transferred it to a primary campaign
yeah but hold on a second here we got to
break these things down and I'm trying
to struggle through the bad connection
here the transferring money thing
listen Bernie transferred money it's
very common to transfer money from one
campaign to another now your first year
party we hold up with a big money
fundraiser right I agree with you there
is a difference which is that Elizabeth
Warren has money previously raised from
corporate PACs
I hope you're completely right as far as
that goes but is there a policy that she
is advocating for now that she didn't
previously is what I'm trying to
understand Medicare for all I don't
think she's really strongly advocating
for it I've heard her say I mean listen
I've said Bernie is stronger a Bernie
says that burnt Medicare for all is the
way people like Bernie superb people
like Warren and Tulsi have kind of
danced around it and they've said yeah
it sounds good but like other ideas are
okay too and whatever so I don't know
that she's really changed on that I
think she's always been sort of into
Medicare for all but not seeing it as
the way well know cuz there was any of
you when she was asked after she won her
Senate race something was like in 2013
yeah and the interviewer was was
implying that she was she supported by
the careful and she set the record
straight and she made very clear that
she told him to go back and look at the
taste because she'd never supported
Medicare for all and that was back to
2013
I've never seen that it's also I mean
people's position to do evolve right
like I'm sure you would you would grant
you know you like Tulsi Elsie says hold
on Dante Tulsi says her position on gay
rights has changed radically do you
consider that to be a genuine change
yeah but there's a process as she
explained how she came to that
conclusion Elizabeth Warren back in 2016
Bernie Sanders was running on Medicare
for all that was the the center of his
campaign he changed and I shall discuss
the national discourse on health care
yeah back in 2016 if she actually
supported Medicare for all she would
have supported Bernie Sanders I have a
video clip on YouTube where I say if
Elizabeth Warren supported all of
Bernie's ideas in 2016 why didn't she
endorse him during the primary so you
and I are aligned there I just think
Dante that we want to be a little more
precise in our criticisms because as I
kind of gently
prod you with questions you're moving
the goal posts and sort of making
different arguments and you know I want
next time you call it I want you to
really do our precise okay all right all
right Dante you know I love you buddy
calling next time in discussion okay
sounds good we'll talk again Dante thank
you for the call we're gonna bump Dante
half a point in our call a rating system
because that was a very very solid call